[Music]
these days a common refrain i keep
hearing is
listen to black women people say it a
lot and when they do they're usually
talking about politics but
there are a few more things you should
listen to a black woman about
let's hear about him in a segment called
listen to a black woman
[Music]
you should listen to a black woman about
andrew cuomo
stop being surprised that white men in
power abuse power please pick new idols
the only celebrity i believe in is
angela bassett and you should too
next covet vaccine i haven't wanted
anything inside of me this bad since i
was a kid
and my aunt told me i couldn't get an
easter basket unless i accepted christ
into my heart
not where you thought i was going with
that one next
pineapple on pizza eat a fruit salad or
eat a pizza you can't be doing
everything at once
you don't see me riding a bike and
playing a video game is dangerous
next helen hunt where has she been
what is she up to she's too quiet and i
don't trust it
next holly hunter that's a different
woman
no they need to consolidate those two
next pets named after another animal
it's very funny every single time
a dog named rabbit oh i'm into it
next paddington three they better not
that movie up i swear to god
next birds shut up i'm trying to sleep
next bell biv devoe okay i would kill
devoe
i would marry oh you just mean the group
as a whole yeah i like them sorry devoe
next jane fonda was that [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] and will always be that
[ __ ] and that's on what
mary had a little lamb buried next
advice for the future never stop
watching the amber ruffin show
and if you're helen hut reach out to
somebody this has been
listen to a black woman
[Music]
eight eight
[Music]
you